halloween stern triple proto
sternensystem und sensationelle lösung
für den klimawandel
das sind drei der fünf themen in den
kick zum top news eisen fressenden
methan oxidieren entdeckt im fachmagazin
proceedings of the national academy of
sciences of the united states of america
wurde eine studie veröffentlicht die
vieles verändern könnte
als forscher einige mikroorganismen
untersucht haben sind sie auf eine
sensation gestoßen
zitat wir sahen uns den genetischen
fingerabdruck dieser mikroorganismen an
und vermuteten dass sie im zuge der
methan oxidation partikuläre reisen im
grunde nichts anderes als rost umsetzen
können diese vermutung überprüften wir
dann im labor und tatsächlich diese
mikroben schafften es so bohr an katar
vom mpi bremen das heißt man hat
mikroben gefunden
rost schnell und einfach beseitigen die
mikrobe stellt damit zudem einen ersten
ernstzunehmenden vertreter der
sogenannten eisen fressenden methan ob
sie die radar und für was kann man diese
erkenntnisse nun verwenden partei weiter
man kann einen bioreaktor bauen der
zweierlei mikroorganismen enthält die
ohne sauerstoff sowohl methan als auch
ammonium umsetzen können in diesem
könnte dann gleichzeitig ammonium methan
und oxidiert der stickstoff aus dem
abwasser in harmloses stickstoffgas und
kohlendioxid umgewandelt werden
kohlendioxid ist deutlich weniger klima
aktiv als methan könnte also bald einen
gewaltigen beitrag zum schutz unserer
umwelt beitragen weltraumroboter in
einem fast eineinhalbstündigen live
public york haben experten der nasa über
den aktuellen stand der space robotik
forschung berichtet wie läuft ein
bohrtests in der schwerelosigkeit ab wie
überwinden roboter fels überhänge das
und mehr erklärt aaron kam es vom nasa
jet propulsion laboratorium in seinem
vortrag einen kleinen teaser gibt es für
euch jetzt hier bei uns und den link zum
ganzen vortag findet ihr hier oben nada
oder da unter mir auf jeden fall
triple system das sternsystem l 148 ps 3
b ist von uns gesehen etwa 750
lichtjahre entfernt und hat forscher wie
im fachmagazin nature zu lesen etwas
ganz besonderes beobachten lassen
bei der analyse des stern systems mit
dem atacama large millimeter
submillimeter array oder kurz alma und
der radioteleskope des very large rx
stießen die astronomen auf ein szenario
das so noch nie beobachtet werden konnte
das in etwa 150.000 jahre sehr junge
system besteht aus drei proto stern und
kann nur durch eine besondere art der
stern geburt entstanden sein
denn wie caitlin creator von der
university of arizona erklärt seien die
zwei äusseren sterne gerade mal 10 bis
20 tausend jahre alt l 14 48 er ist 3b
kann also nicht wie andere sternsysteme
aus einer dichten staub und gaswolken
entstanden sein die zwei jüngeren sterne
sollen lange nach der geburt des ersten
sterns aus dessen zukunft der langen
gas- schreibe entstanden sein konto bin
von der university of oklahoma bestätigt
die vermutung zitat dass es zwei
mechanismen für die bildung solcher
mehrling sternensysteme gibt zum einen
ist dies die aufspaltung von
zukunftsszenarien glasscheiben wie wir
es hier sehen zum anderen kann dies
durch fragmentierung der ganzen gaswolke
in der sternen wege stehen
zitat ende halloween stern das klingt
jetzt wirklich stark inszeniert aber die
nasa hat tatsächlich einen stern
entdeckt der die form eines zu halloween
so beliebten gewächses hat nämlich eines
kürbis
ein halloween stern und auch genau jetzt
ihr glaubt mir nicht seht selbst wie
pumpkin star
ende des klimawandels in sicht
kohlenstoffdioxid als kraftstoff also
co2 forscher des oak ridge national
laboratories in tennessee usa haben
sensationelles entdeckt im zuge ihres
lang und aufwendig angesetzten projektes
sind sie direkt zu beginn über die
lösung für den klimawandel gestolpert
wie sie in ihrem artikel in der
fachzeitschrift chemistry select
schreiben habe man mit hilfe einer
nanotechnologie aus der kombination von
kohlenstoff und kupfer 0 gewinnen können
und das resultat kann sich wirklich
sehen lassen weit über die hälfte der
aus der zusammenführung entstanden
stoffe besteht aus dem alkohol ethanol
im prozent seien es etwa 65
was von wissenschaftlern lange
vorbereitet werden musste stellte sich
nun als einfacher umsetzbar heraus zitat
in dem der herkömmliche materialien mit
nanotechnologie kombinierten fanden wir
heraus wie wir neben reaktionen
eingrenzen können und am ende nur das
erhalten was wir eigentlich haben wollen
das sagte er dem rodino ne einer der
forscher für den wettlauf gegen den
klimawandel könnte diese arbeit welche
übrigens die einzige mit einem solchen
resultat ist von großer bedeutung sein
co2 ist ja neben methan einer der
auslöser allen übels wie sieht die
zukunft aus diese frage hat sich cedric
in einem seiner videos auf dem kanal d
erwachsen gestellt das video ist ins
finale des vereins wettbewerbs gekommen
um die zuschauer können mitleids und
kommentaren entscheiden welches video
gewinnt schaut euch sein video bitte
bitte an und wenn ihr cedrick
unterstützen wollt dann live das video
unkommentiert was das zeug hält den link
dazu findet ihr hier und doktor watson
könnt ihr hier abonnieren ich freue mich
über eure kommentare und natürlich likes
abos und das ganze programm
bis dann bleibt dran